look after a long investigation after so  many people have been so badly hurt  after not looking at the other side  where a lot of bad things happened a lot  of horrible things happen a lot of very  bad things happen for our country it was  just announced there was no collusion  with Russia the most ridiculous thing  I've ever heard  there was no collusion with Russia there  was no obstruction and none whatsoever  and it was a complete and total  exoneration it's a shame that our  country had to go through this to be  honest it's a shame that your president  has had to go through this for before I  even got elected it began and it began  illegally and hopefully somebody's going  to look at the other side this was an  illegal takedown that failed and  hopefully somebody's going to be looking  at the other side so it's complete  exoneration no collusion no obstruction  thank you very much thank you